Hello, good afternoon.
Ira.
How's it going?
Abe.
All good, all good. How about you?
Doing pretty good.
How's your week?
It's been good.
Perfect. Anything new to you, your work, your family?
Thank you.
I'll share a picture with you. My daughter had her first school play. And so she was very excited.
Show you as we.
First ever school play.
Yeah.
Wow.
So, shh, so my daughter is the pirate.
Oh wow, in the middle.
Seven.
Yeah, right there. So that was the end. It was hard to explain. The play was like designed, like written for children to do and stuff, but it was about time travel and different periods of history. And so there were cowboys and pirates and disco dancers and all sorts of different things.
So it was good. She was really, she was very excited. I don't think she slept much, if at all, the night before. So she was, she was excited.
Wow.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's awesome. I just went to the beach with my family, so whenever I have time, I really wanted to go to the beach. I really wanted the ambience, the serenity, the peace that it gives me whenever.
How about you?
I'm very in the beach, seeing the water. Yeah, but that's what I want whenever I have time. How about you?
Nice.
I like the woods. I prefer the woods. My wife, my wife is a beach person. I'm a woods person. And so we live, we live in the woods. And when we, when we, and when we travel, we go to the beach usually. So, so.
Woods.
PH.
Yeah.
Yeah, contradicting.
PH.
Fantastic. Again, good thing that we had fun. Moving on, thank you for joining our weekly, bi-weekly service call. So let me just quickly share my screen. Let me know once it is visible.
And by the way, Andy won't be able to join today. She has a personal emergency.
Sorry to hear that.
She has a personal emergency, Andrea. She can join today.
No.
I'm sorry, I just said I'm sorry to hear that.
Oh, I thought you didn't hear me. Yeah, her auntie died.
Ohh, I'm sorry.
So today is the funeral, yeah. Bad thing. Anyways, this review would be from March 30th to April 10th.
K.
Agenda items are pretty much the same.
Check in, this is for you. How are things at this moment for both Sheila and Nigel? Can you tell me more?
Sure. So I think Nigel continues to be a rock star. Whatever we need to do to make him happy, please keep him happy. Sheila, we're a little worried about based on attendance. You know, there have been, I would say, and I'd like to, I don't even, I'd have to look at my records, but
Seems like she's had more sick time than I would expect from somebody at this kind of stage in the game. And so something to just keep an eye on. Her work performance has not been a problem at all. I just want to make sure we keep an eye on that. And then I know Steve received a message. I'm not sure if you're
PH.
in on all of these, but about a potential like transportation workers strike in the Philippines and Sheila might need to work from home for certain days. Is that something that still needs to be approved or has it been approved?
Mhm.
I'll have to check in with Manu. It's Manu who our site head, our site director, who's communicating with your side of defense. But then for what I know, we have an upcoming strike this Monday, 21st.
Okay.
Yep.
So if that can be approved, that will be helpful for the both of them. Oh, it's going to be on Tuesday. So they have announced that they will be on strike this coming Tuesday. So we need your confirmation. If you would approve it, if it's okay with you, we can.
S.
Let's get it to both of them.
Got it. So we were only asked about Sheila. I assume that's because Nigel has his own car, but will it be difficult to move around on those days? Like does he need to?
Yes, he is.
stay home as well or can he come in because he has his own car?
Yeah, he can come in in the office, but then moving forward, if the price increases, we're not really sure, but one of our BCP is to implement a four-day work week as well, but that hasn't been discussed yet to you guys. I'm just giving you a heads up.
Yeah.
That's one of our plans. So it's something that you can also consider. But for Nigel, since he has the means to go to the office, we can have him travel. We can have him work on site. And for Sheila, maybe she will have difficulty
OK.
Got it.
traveling to the office on the 21st. So if you could look at it and send an email as well to Manu, if you could respond to that.
So that wasn't, that was sent to Steve, the owner of Atlantic PC. It wasn't sent to me. So he and Manu will have to follow up or send it to me to approve. That would be fine too. In general, stuff should be sent to me and not Steve. He doesn't, he's not, he's not really very responsive.
Yu.
Okay.
Oh.
Okay, gotcha. I'll forward the feedback to Manu. I'll have him forward the email to you instead. We still have time.
Yeah.
Yeah, and just put Steve, anything that he sends to, you know, it's not that I want to cut Steve out. Anything he sends to Steve, he should just include me on as well, and I'll make sure that it gets responded to.
Okay, perfect. So he's not around, but then we still have time on Monday. I'll have that figured out.
I don't know if she has the infrastructure at home. I think part of it was, does she have the requisite internet connection and technology at home to even be able to work? I don't know the answer to that.
Mm.
Bing.
Yep, she she has. I also I did ask her about it. We, before we reached out to you, we did have a connect with her and she confirmed that her work set up, it's all good. Her now her home network, her room.
Got it.
You did.
It's for work. Yeah, she can do it.
Got it. Okay, cool.
Okay, but then I'll forward you the email. I'll just have to discuss this to Manu. Thanks for pointing that out. And then for the action tracker, it's for Sheila's onboarding and for the ride cage is for AJ.
Okay.
OK.
She's not around today.
No.
Okay, it's fine. But then I'll probably have to send him or message him about this. It's no rush. I just wanted to know if we could create a dashboard for Sheila as well. That would help me get or maybe it would help me.
Okay.
Create her scorecard monthly because I need the SLA if there's no bridge and everything, the handling time for each ticket and all of that. Have to check in with AJ, right? For this breakage? Okay. And for the onboarding, as far as I can remember.
Yeah.
Yes.
You're still working on it, right?
Do you really still need that?
It's fine. Maybe I just need the access or the 90 days tracker and if you're good, we can close this one. But no rush. Okay, moving on to the performance analysis. This is just for Nigel.
Okay.
Sounds good.
because I'm still trying to figure out how I can track Sheila's performance. So for Nigel, it's pretty good. Our target is 80%. That's the standard. If we can see from the chart, the average is 75. So
Yep.
Oh, we're short for 5%, but then it's still a good number for Nigel because for this part, the first week he did have like 3 days PTO. So if you can see, there's just two blues. And for...
6th to 10th, this is it. So there's like a drop from 9th to 10th.
But then...
I'd be interested to see the overlap because I know like there have been whole days that he's been covering for Sheila. So I wonder if the days that he that she is out, obviously I don't, you know, his billable time goes down when she's out. Of course it did. So.
Yeah.
Mm-mm.
Yes.
Yeah, that's one of the reasons I can take a look at that. So if that's the case, because I'm just using the billable on our end, I'll have to check that. But then 75% is still good, right?
For sure. No, and I would just, I'd be, you know, on your end, if you know, I would just, he shouldn't be held to that higher number on days when he's covering 100% for Sheila. So we should give him a little grace there if that was the case.
Yeah.
OK, I can double-check that.
Those should be like freebie days.
Yeah, I agree for this part.
That's April 9th, 10th, right?
I can have that double check.
Yeah, and I'm not even sure those are the days, but I just, you know, with her having been out recently and his numbers, it seems to make sense.
Let me see.
So not be lazy and pull up the days.
Nine 10th.
No, I can see if she does around those days.
Yeah, I had the 6th, the 30th, and the 31st for her as days off, which is actually not crazy to only have had three days off, just anecdotally it feels like more recently.
Mhm.
Yeah.
So.
Yeah, but for the PTOs, if they're not around, if they're on sick leave, we're not counting or not adding it to the result. So for this one, I guess just a slow day for you guys, the 9th and 10th of April.
Like.
Sure, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, that was that was right before Easter and during Passover too, right? I think.
Ohh.
Gotcha. Okay. For the ticket closure trend, you can see he's very good with closing on tickets. So our target is 8 to 10th. If you can see here, from the first week, he was able to close
12 out of 12. So that's 100%. And for the following week, he did close 83% average. So in terms of closing tickets, I can see that he's working really hard to once whenever he's being, there's a ticket assigned.
I can see that he wanted to close it and not escalate everything. And from our one on one connect, he also wanted to, you know, work on complicated tickets. He doesn't want to be, yeah, yeah, yeah. Any plans though?
Yeah.
Yep, we've started talking about that internally as well.
So, we're gonna...
Absolutely. I mean, we've told, I mean, anything that he feels comfortable doing, we're comfortable. I mean, I don't want to say anything, but yes, we're comfortable sending him more complicated tickets. And we talked about that on the dispatch side too.
No.
Gotcha, yeah. That's what he wanted. That's what he enjoys a lot when he receives complicated tickets. So sometimes when there's not a lot of choice, he's working on password resets and everything, but given a chance, he wanted to work on network issues.
something like that. Yeah, that's his niche. And any questions so far for the ticket closure trend?
Yeah, good.
Nope, no, I'm good.
Nope, alright.
Next up, oops, hold on. Yes, for the CSAT, these are from your clients. We have two. One's from Maria. She said that Nigel clearly explained everything and very thorough with solving my issue.
And the other one was from Florence. Technician was knowledgeable about the issue and was able to resolve my issue quickly. Thank you, Nigel. That's wonderful to hear.
Very nice.
And...
How do you pronounce the customer, the company, Cuber?
Gruber.
Paula Mary and Raphael.
Okay, Cooper, Palmeri, Raphael. Okay.
Not.
Yeah, Gruber Palmeri, Raphael Freed, CPA.
Refile, OK. Ohh, accounting, accounting.
A lot of times we would just do the letters internally. So internally, rather than trying to say all that, we would just say GPRF.
GPMR.
Is that an accounting firm?
Yeah, CPA is AccountingPH.
Gotcha. Okay.
CPA stands for Certified Public Accountants.
Gotcha. Right. For the products, you already know this. If in case you need any of this, you can reach out to us.
Kour.
For the way forward, we have three. The upcoming holiday, the reason why I pinged you yesterday, if you have a copy of your company holiday for 2026, is May 1st, the Labor Day, also a holiday for you guys? Or we need them to work.
Let me just check the observed date on it.
May 1st is Friday.
Yeah.
Yes, that's correct.
Okay, so now work for us.
Right.
Fantastic. And we have PTO requests for Nigel. It's May 11th to 12. Would you like me to send you an email for this one?
Yeah, if you can send it to that, the PTO at address that goes to the right distribution.
Okay, perfect. I'll send both for Sheila. It's going to be on May 8th.
All right. Next up, yep, this is the part where we chit chat. So I don't have anything to discuss apart from their performance analysis. And I'm glad that we've been hearing good feedback for the both of them. As for Sheila's attendance,
I actually did coach her about this the other day. It's like a sword throat thing. So she tried to work the other day, but then yesterday she can't, she can no longer speak. So she wanted to rest.
Sure.
Yeah, no, and don't push it with it. I mean, I looked at it and, you know, three days within the time she spent, not a big deal. Just something, it was brought up to me and I repeated it. And then, you know, like I said, let's just keep an eye on her. But you see her every day, you know, if she's, you know,
Mhm.
Yeah, yes.
not really sick or if she can't speak, right? And so I trust your judgment 100%.
Of course, of course. I, when I checked, it's just like from March, there's one instance and this April one as well. But then I'll keep an eye on it. I'll make sure that they understand that we need coverage for every day, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
No.
But the...
And in the same, on one hand, yes, that, and on the other hand, I don't want sick people making the rest of your office sick. And so they need to stay home when they're sick. And so I wouldn't even mention it to her. We'll keep an eye on it internally. But I never, I want people to take their time off, and especially when they're sick.
Yes.
Of course.
because people do a horrible job when they're sick anyways.
Mhm.
I know. And also we have a corrective action for that. We currently, we're implementing the penalty points. So whenever they reach a certain amount, there's a disciplinary action. The worst case would be termination.
Got it.
Okay, yeah, don't let's not do that. Let's not do that. Yeah, and talk to me first.
Yeah, but then that's eight points. Yeah, of course, of course I'll do. But then they know it. They're pretty cautious about those penalty. So don't worry about it. I'll let you know if I see any pattern so we can discuss. All right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Anything else, Doc?
Alright, what?
No, I would say just keep me in the loop on the implications of the energy or the travel or the, I'm sorry, transportation strike. And, you know, I know there are, you know, energy prices are going to be a problem for everybody if we have to do some sort of
All right.
stipend for Nigel, you know, if gas prices are double what they were, you know, something like that, you know, let's talk about it. So.
Mhm.
Yeah, he's actually joking though. He said that he's also affected because he's paying for the gas and everything. And then I told him, and then I told him, sell your car.
Yeah, no, no, it's true.
You sound even mean, you sound like that.
No, I'm just kidding.
No, we're just kidding everyone. But then, you know, we're trying our best, the management side, we're trying our best to mitigate the issue. That's why I'm telling you about the four-day work week plan, but that's not really, we're not implementing it yet because we're checking on your side first, if that's going to be a case.
Parth.
Yeah.
there's a security risk, then we can't really do that. But then if you're okay with it, then we can go for it. But then if not, we have to make an adjustment, maybe an allowance or everything. But yeah, that's not actually, that's out of my scope.
Yeah, you haven't figured. No, just...
I'm just waiting for the higher-ups.
Just anecdotally, I would be, I would rather pay people some sort of emergency transportation stipend while the, while you know, there's an elevation in gas prices than switch to foreign one and start having people work from home. But obviously, we'll do what we have to do based on what's happening in the world. And
So, we'll see, we'll see what happens.
Yeah. So if in case you receive the email, you can also give your options, like what you think is the best thing to do for this one. So we would appreciate if you have ideas. All right. I know. You're very straightforward.
Sure.
Of course.
I'm not shy, you know that.
And I like that, anyways.
Well, I appreciate you very much, and thank you for putting up with me.
Aarav.
Am I straightforwardness?
Thank you for putting up. Thank you for putting up with us as well. I know it's been tough lately, you know, what happened. But then you're still here and we appreciate you.
I don't even, I don't even look at it that way. I, you know, we've we've hired three people with you guys and two of them have worked out. You're still doing better than my US average.
Yes.
Yay, I'm glad to hear that.
So, right? I mean...
All right, take care. Have a great weekend.
All right. Thank you for joining this service call and see you in the next two weeks. Doug. Enjoy your weekend. Bye-bye. Thank you.
Perfect. You too. Take care. Thanks. Bye.